nation is in peril those are the words
of the former Prime Minister Tony Blair
after last week's vote to leave the
European Union but is the party he led
so successfully in any position to save
the nation given Labour's own turmoil
well I'm joined now by the former Prime
Minister Tony Blair and a very good
morning to you and in that article you
wrote some people are interpreting that
as you putting yourself forward in some
way to to help with the brexit
negotiations that's got to be done by
the government not not by me
the reason I'm concerned is is this the
the strange thing about the whole
referendum is that we had a vote in the
vote was 52 to 48 to leave the European
Union but we have no idea what lies on
the other side of that and there's a
hugely complex negotiation that's now
got to take place in which we need to
see exactly what is the offer what does
brexit look like when we see the state
of the negotiation what happens to our
business to our jobs to our investment
to our economy as a result of this
negotiation so my plea is very simple
right at this moment we have to keep
absolutely fixed on trying to ensure
that negotiation is set up in the right
way for our interests and secondly as a
country we should keep all our options
open for this right now we don't really
know what lies on the other side and
given your concerns are for the nation
you know we in effect don't have a
government we have a prime minister
who's who's leaving this so-called lame
duck what you say to the Conservative
Party about the speed of its it's
processed for the good of the nation to
get a prime minister in place who can
undertake that task I just hope the
Conservative Party puts the national
interests first
but the difficulty with having a
leadership election within a political
party is that very naturally what
happens is all the focuses within the
party and the Conservative Party I think
they've got a 150,000 or 200,000 members
is it I mean let's assume most of them
apparently are probe wrecks it and the
average age is probably towards the
upper scale but you've got a 48% of this
country who I think feel quite
politically disenfranchised they feel
young people particularly I think feel
very angry about the result they think
they've been deprived of the the future
they wanted
for our country and at this moment I
still think David Cameron being the
Prime Minister has got an important role
in trying to shape how the rest of
Europe is going to handle this
negotiation because you've got 27
different countries 27 governments 27
Parliament's the European Parliament
each of these details is a thousand
Devils in it it's a very very
complicated negotiation and each one of
them concerns a job or a sector or
someone's livelihood I mean just
listening to the size of that task we're
gonna need tens of thousands of new
bureaucrats are we just doing
negotiators just to get involved in that
and negotiating everything from the
fundamental trade deals to where the
melton mowbray pork-pies keeps its name
well if we come out of the European
single market which of course is the
first big question do you do do you go
to negotiate to get back into the single
market that that in a sense invalidates
your reason for the brexit or do you
leave that to a World Trade Organisation
type negotiation which with any of us
have experienced the World Trade
Organization I mean this would be this
will be years before we get our position
clarified the most important thing right
now is you've got a situation where okay
it's clear there was a vote to leave but
it wasn't 70/30 or 60/40 it was 52-48 I
mean let's be very blunt about it some
of the claims made for the brexit case
of somewhat collapsed even in the week
since we've been doing this I mean you
find conservative people who were
campaigning for Briggs it saying a few
years ago it actually would be disaster
to leave the EU so you've got a very
strange atmosphere I realize this right
and the most important thing right at
this moment is to make sure that we
shape the psychology and the thinking of
the other 27 countries do you think I
mean within that analysis then Mr Blair
do you think then that we ought to keep
our options open in particular
triggering article 50 which sets in
train and the formal process to leave
the European Union do you think that
that ought to be left alone for quite a
while now while the nation in the
political class absorb what has happened
well there will be a limit to how long
we can do that but absolutely
think we should keep all our options
open but how long for well frankly in my
view for as long as it takes to get an
idea of what the other side looks like I
mean what is it that we're going to
agree what is our the real impact on
business I mean you know just talking to
people in different parts of the world
in the last few days look we've got to
be under no doubt at all Britain is a
strong country it's a good country a
creative country our economy in the end
I'm sure can come through but round the
world there is huge anxiety people do
think we've done greater than diminished
our standing and so there's a whole
series of things that are going to
become apparent over the next few months
that aren't apparent now but there is a
there is a problem with that isn't it
that we hear from our all branches of
the European Union from individual
countries from individual leaders as
well within the European Union that no
negotiations can take place with the UK
until article 50 is triggered you think
there's a way around that
well there's negotiation in the formal
sense of working out the details of exit
and yes that's that's triggered by
article 50 but there's a whole thing
that can be done before then I mean I
personally would have right now someone
very senior I would even say the prime
minister or the Chancellor visiting
every capital in Europe see what the
room for manoeuvre is seeing what they
might really want understanding their
politics each of these countries are
different politics that politics will
determine their attitude to us and okay
in the immediate aftermath of the vote
there's a certain hostility but you know
we've got to treat this like a you know
a vast campaign for our national
interest and we've also gotten one of
the reasons why we should keep our
options open is yes the referendum
expressed the will of the people but you
know the will of the people is entitled
to change and so we should keep an eye
also in Parliament's got a very
important role here MPs will be getting
feedback from their constituencies
they've got to analyse the detail of
what starts to emerge but right now over
this next two months even whilst this
you know frankly psychodrama within the
Conservative Party is going on we've got
to have the national interest protected
by trying to set the scene for any
negotiation so are you saying I think
though this could be revisited
be a second referendum or that
Parliament could override the vote and I
don't think you can override the settle
will of the people but my point is very
simple you know it's 52 to 48 supposing
some weeks or months down the line as it
becomes clear what we're moving to
because as I say the odd thing about the
referendum is we knew what we were
getting out of we don't know what we're
getting into as that becomes clear if if
it's clear that these terms are bad for
us if we have major parts of business
and the financial sector saying that
this is not a good deal for us if people
start to worry about their jobs you know
we should just keep our options open I'm
not saying we have another referendum
I'm not saying you can revisit this I'm
simply saying there's no rule about this
we we're a sovereign people we can do
what we want to do and Parliament no of
course it shouldn't override the will of
the people but it is also the job of
Parliament to express the will of the
people and to make sure that they
scrutinize carefully what this new deal
might be in normal times this Sun this
vacuum would be a great opportunity for
a strong opposition to capitalize on it
what are your thoughts about what Jeremy
Corbyn is doing to the party you used to
lead should he go so I have resolutely
refused it intervene in this debate
about whether Jeremy called Masjid stay
or go it's frankly I I don't know what's
happening right now within the Labour
Party I'm not part of any move one way
or another but he lost he lost that vote
of no-confidence I mean that had
happened to you I mean I knew Italian
formally that was it that was a
situation you went I think most people
probably guess my views on this but I
don't I don't want to intervene Alex I
don't think it's helpful for me to do so
but I do make this well I've got to put
it to you Mr Blair then you are you are
not disagreeing with me when I say you
think mr. Gorbachev oh no no no it's
pretty words in my mouth the point I
want to make slightly different and I
think it's a more appropriate point for
me to make for a democracy to function
you've got to have an opposition with a
minimum level of credibility to
challenge the government and to hold it
to account especially at a moment when
that 48% is feeling deeply
disenfranchised
when there is this huge negotiation of
national interest on the table so you
need to have that and if the opposition
is incapacitated for any reason it
allows frankly what's been happening
within the Conservative Party to happen
because they can do whatever they want
because they think they're going to be
the government at the end of the day so
I'm not saying Jericho should stay or go
I'm not expressing an opinion of that
I'm simply making one very simple point
right now at this moment of time this
country needs an opposition that is
capable of challenging the government
holding it to account and representing
those millions of people out there who
are thinking back on the last week and
thinking our country's been changed
we've got no one to represent us so you
say which it currently doesn't have that
opposition well it's pretty obvious and
everything's going on the last few days
it's been it's it's it's a I mean look I
am not known at a time like this in
British politics to be honest well one
of the reasons we're told were hearing
today that to Jeremy Corbyn is hanging
on so resolutely as he wants to wait
till Wednesday and the Chilkoot report
coming out and wants to crucify you
according to one of his aides for being
a war criminal so Wednesday is the time
the reports published and I've said many
times over these past years I'll wait
for the report and then I will make my
views known and and and express myself
fully and properly and I just I've taken
the view I think rightly or wrongly we
should wait for the report to be
published and then I'll express myself
and I'm not getting into either the
politics or the detail of it before we
actually see but just link it to the
party I mean you know there must be
times when you wonder when other people
wonder why do sections of the very party
that you devoted your political life and
soul to why do they hate you so
fundamentally I don't know there may be
lots of reasons for it but you know
politics is a and politics is a strange
business but you've always got to think
back and and think that it's a-you know
I'd also great times leading the Labour
Party and you know despite all the
controversies over issues like Iraq
there were many many good things that we
managed to do for the country so you've
got to to take
a sort of long view of this and think
that in the end whatever people say in
politics today is a pretty rough
business people say pretty unpleasant
things about each other there's still a
an important job to be done in a job
which if you manage to get to it and do
it as leader of the Labour Party or
prime minister you should count yourself
privileged but it is this issue isn't it
being called a war criminal Alex Salmond
the SMPS coming along on the program a
bit later and I'm sure he's going to
endorse she did that that korbinite view
and some people saying there are grounds
for you to be arrested and taken to the
International Criminal Court you know
it's been around for some time how do
you treat that I think it's best we wait
for Wednesday and then let's see what
what the report brings and and when it
comes by the way then I I can respond
properly but it's not possible and
certainly not really okay appropriate I
think for me to respond but you could
tell us now because one of the key
questions that one of the key questions
is what understanding did you come to
with george w bush before 2003 the
Crawford ranch conversation did you know
that pledge did you pledge the bready
went back the United States come what
may these are the very things the
reports going to go into and you know
where Sunday we've got the report on
Wednesday let's wait and see it and then
as I say there will be a very very full
debate and I will be I can absolutely
assure you no case abating in it very
fully can they just roll all these
issues together then I mean it occurs to
me looking at your political career are
the three big pillars on which you based
it falling apart you wanted to make the
Labour Party a progressive force almost
forevermore and certainly keep it in
power and allow it to make make an
influence you wanted to as one of the
phrases during the campaign just gone
you wanted to make Britain lead not
leave the European Union and in foreign
policy terms you wanted to show the
ability of nations like our own to
intervene ethically in foreign affairs
and make things better
yeah and these things are under
challenge but you know politics it goes
in in in waves of sentiment and feeling
and I think the most important thing in
politics is to do what you think is is
right in the end
you may be right or wrong but ultimately
I think leadership is about assessing
the situation as you as you see it and
then doing what you think is is right
even if it's not always very popular and
you know yes I stood for those things
when I was leader of the Labour Party I
stand for them still but I'm very
confident over time these arguments can
reassert themselves and you know
politics today is a it's it's a very
rough business and it's made
particularly rough because politicians
today operate with this kind of wall of
noise around them created by
conventional media interacting with
social media so that you I think
sometimes politicians are quite
disoriented and you've always got to go
back to first principles you know why is
it important that Labour is a party of
government not a party of protests so it
can change the country for the better
why is important that we're in Europe
because in the 21st century being part
of a major alliance and commercial
market is in the interests of the
country why why is it important that we
are engaged in the world and prepared to
intervene because this is a world more
integrated than ever before and a
security problem in one part in the
world is a security problem here so
these arguments they're not they're not
gone away they're there they're still
there and and I've no doubt at all that
as a new generation comes through though
they will find advocates of it tell them
I'll send you there thank you very much